كيف تطالب واشنطن والغرب بحسب موقفهم من
ارسال الدبابات وانظمه الدفاع الجوي
الغربيه باسرع وقت لان اوكرانيا لا تملك
الوقت ولكن على ارض الواقع هل يؤدي منح
الغرب دبابات لاوكرانيا لانتصارها ام
يوقعها في الفخ الذي سقطت به روسيا قبلها
صحيفه الجاردن البريطانيه اوضحت في تقرير
لها ان توفير دبابات القتال الرئيسيه
المصممه من النيته يمثل بعض التحديات
الرئيسيه لان دبابات ليوبار تو الالمانيه
التي تزن حوالي 69 طنا تشالنجر البريطانيه
التي تزن حوالي 72 وطنا اثقل بمقدار 20
طنا من دبابات القتال الرئيسيه المصممه من
الاتحاد السوفيتي والتي تشغلها اوكرانيا
حاليا والبنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه
مشاهدينا لا تسمح لمثل هذه المركبات
الثقيله السفر على طولها في حين ان
مركباتها الهندسيه وعربه الاصلاح مخصصه
لدعم التصاميم السوفياتيه حصرا تحدي اخر
توجهك لان الدبابات المصممه من النيته
تحتاج الى تدريبات مكثفه لاستخدامها في
ساحه المعركه اما من ناحيه التكتيك الحربي
فقد توقع دبابات النيته اوكرانيا بالفخ
عينه الذي وقعت فيه موسكو في بدايه الحرب
لانه قد يشجعها على تنفيذ هجوم مكشوف وقد
تصبح طوابير الدبابات الغربيه الصنع في يد
الاوكرانيين هدفا لاصول المروحيات
والطائرات النفاثه الروسيه مثل طائرات
سوخوي 25 مثل ما كانت الدبابات الروسيه
خلالها هجوم كيا في الربيع هدفا لهجمات
الصواريخ الاوكرانيه المحموله على الكتف
والطائرات المسيره من طراز برقدار التركي
تركيا
[موسيقى]